somewhere out there beyond the moon but
not quite past Jupiter is roughly 5
meter-wide space rock that may one day
get a more permanent home near Earth
within the next decade or so NASA wants
to capture that asteroid and haul it to
the moon relocating the rock is part of
the asteroid redirect mission which
could help humans get ready for an
eventual trip to Mars or so nASA says
politics aside the agency's two plans to
nab a space rock and bring it closer to
the moon are pretty fantastic in the
first scenario a spacecraft will blast
off from Earth and sail through the
solar system toward the asteroid when
positioned just right the spacecraft
will unfurl a bag that when inflated
will stretch about as tall as a
three-story building and hold an
asteroid weighing up to a thousand tons
the bag will then be slipped around the
rock and cinched shut like a garbage
sack the spacecraft will fire up its
engines and slowly gently begin nudging
the rock toward its new orbit around the
moon a journey that could take years
NASA's second proposed plan to nab a
space rock involves a robot with some
combination of arms legs and possibly
thousands of little hooks this robot
will be designed to snatch a golf cart
size Boulder off the target asteroid and
shuttle it to the moon but the hunk of
rock won't go from deep space to the
moon without leaving its parent asteroid
completely unaffected if nasa chooses
this concept the agency wants to tug on
the asteroid with a gravity tractor the
tugging would use the tiny attraction
between the boulder snatching spacecraft
and the parent asteroid the idea would
test a technique that could one day help
nudge huge space rocks off course and
keep them from hitting Earth ultimately
NASA wants to bring an asteroid to the
moon so that humans can explore it the
space agency argues that either scenario
will help get people closer to the red
planet without the mission the u.s. may
not have much of a future in human space
exploration of course only time will
tell if the moon will one day get a
rocky satellite of its own